Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Genau, genau das ist das.
Das wollte ich mal spielen.
Das hab ich in einen,
ich glaub in einem Speedrun-Marathon mal gesehen.
Das sah so ein bisschen...
Sieht so ein bisschen Metroid-Style mäßig aus.
Wenn ich das hier also
Zumindest auf den ersten Eindruck.
Wo man das hier mit dieser Übersichtskarte...
Wo man das gerade von unterschiedlichen Räumen gesehen hat.
Kennt das jemand?
Hat das jemand schon gespielt?
Äh, MrFiech, Max, spielst du eigentlich noch Konsole?
Spielst du eigentlich noch Konsole? Ja, ich hab öfters. Also Switch, hauptsächlich.
Ich mein, man sieht's jetzt hier nicht. Ich hab jetzt hier den riesen Konsolenturm mittlerweile links neben mir stehen.
Das steht unten. Unten steht, Moment, was ist denn das, was unten steht? Das ist die Xbox One, die unten steht.
Das fetteste von allen ist die Xbox One. Das ist die Release von 2013. Xbox One.
Dann drüber stehen hab ich die 360. Danach hab ich eine Wii U und eine PS4 und die Switch steht drüben.
Wo ist eigentlich meine PS3? Ah, die steht unten im Regal, okay.
Hollow Knight ist richtig gut, okay. Ich glaub, man kann da auch nicht allzu viel falsch machen, wenn man jetzt nicht...
Das war 9,89 Euro.
Xbox, da wo sie hingehört, ganz unten. Die Xbox, die hab ich... Also ich hab ja diesen... Wo ist denn der Controller?
Da steht irgendwie sowas... Egal, ich brauch jetzt die Controller nicht, aber auf dem Xbox Controller steht irgendwie sowas drauf wie 2013 Xbox Release Edition und sowas.
Und ich hab die Konsole vielleicht insgesamt 5 Stunden angehabt seit 2013.
Und ich muss euch noch was zeigen, grad mal, falls es davon was gibt. Ich hab da nämlich, glaub ich, kein Foto von.
Ich hab nämlich ein T-Shirt von Microsoft. Das ist absolut die brutalste Übertreibung aller Zeiten.
Ich hoffe, es hat jemand von diesem T-Shirt ein Foto gemacht. Da kann ich es euch nämlich mal zeigen.
Na, fuck. Nee, ich find's nicht. Ich hab nämlich von Microsoft ein T-Shirt übelst dick aufgetragen.
Da waren wir damals auf der Gamescom.
Und also quasi noch bevor die Gamescom losgegangen ist, am ersten Tag bei Microsoft.
Und wir waren da irgendwie... Das haben wir erst später gemerkt. Ich glaub, die Story hab ich schon mal erzählt.
Microsoft hat halt so gefragt, ja und Jungs, wollt ihr vorbeikommen?
Wir haben gesagt, ja klar, cool. Können wir uns das angucken? Gibt's danach was zu futtern? Geil, gucken wir uns an.
Also wir wurden quasi direkt von Microsoft eingeladen, der Felix und ich.
Und haben gesagt, ja machen wir. Bis wir es dann gecheckt haben, als wir drinnen waren, als sie wollten, dass wir uns Xbox-T-Shirts anziehen und in die ersten zwei Reihen hocken.
Wir waren quasi die Vorklatscher für die Microsoft Presse... also die Anfeuerer für die Microsoft Presse Konferenz.
Ich glaub, das hab ich schon mal erzählt. Zumindest seit dem Tag hab ich so ein komisches Xbox-T-Shirt.
Das ist eines meiner Lieblings-T-Shirts, weil es passt echt gut.
Wahrscheinlich haben sich gedacht, die Leute, die da kommen, sind eh alle mega fett, deswegen brauchen wir fette T-Shirts.
Und seitdem hab ich ein Xbox-T-Shirt, wo hinten ganz bescheiden, so wie Microsoft ist, drauf steht.
Ich war, also, sinngemäß steht da drauf, ich war dabei, als die größten Games aller Zeiten gezeigt wurden.
Jetzt müsst ihr euch vorstellen, das war die Gamescom 2014 oder so. Microsoft Presse Konferenz.
Wo sie unter anderem Scalebound oder Spellbound-T-Shirts, wie hieß das? Scalebound?
Ich glaub, Scalebound hieß das, gezeigt haben, ich hab sogar noch ein Scalebound.
Wie heißt denn das Game mit dem Drache, was sie jetzt eingestellt haben?
Spellbound?
Nee, Scalebound hieß das, ne? Scalebound.
Genau, ich hab sogar noch ein Scalebound-T-Shirt und das ist ja mittlerweile eingestellt.
Das haben sie mit Riesentam da eingekündigt und jetzt dann eingestellt.
Seitdem hab ich so ein Xbox-T-Shirt, wo halt ganz bescheiden und fett drauf steht.
I witness the greatest games of all time, Xbox.
So, also das Game, das hab ich mal in einem Stream gesehen, das ist echt ganz nice.
Ich glaub, das machen wir uns auch mal in Card.
Was ist das?
Hoffentlich zeigt es nicht meine Adresse ans Team, ey.
Ok, was gibt's denn sonst noch? Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt, was ist das?
Er hat auch alles, oder?
Der Drache, der hat auch alles. Der ist ja überall an jedem Game, wo ich hier drüber gehe.
One friend owns this game. Der hat auch alles. Gibt nix, was er nicht hat.
Was ist das? Weltraumstels. Oh, das ist was von Fabian.
Übrigens, mit dem Friseur kommt nachher ein Video, wir haben gestern mal zusammen aufgenommen.
Oh, ich muss mal Chat lesen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Das sieht mir ein bisschen aus nach Weltraumstels. Grafisch ganz hübscher Weltraumstels, muss ich sagen.
Grafisch ganz hübscher Weltraumstels. Der echte. Der echte, ja.
Wollte ich eigentlich um 13 Uhr freischalten? Mal gucken, wenn wir mit dem Stream fertig sind.
Max hat irgendwo mal gesagt, dass er ein offizielles Face Reveal macht, wenn er 1.000.000 Subs bekommen wird.
Das hab ich echt mal gesagt.
Äh, ich muss mal...
So, was haben wir sonst noch, ja? Planet Coaster, naaah. Naah.
Auch wenn ich früher die, wie hieß es denn, Railroad Tycoon, Railroad, Railcoaster Tycoon oder das, ihr wisst was ich meine, übelst geil fand.
Ich glaub nicht, dass es an die alten Teile rankommt.
Sagen wir mal die Bewertung. Rollercoaster Tycoon, genau. Ja, stimmt, PTF. Ist einfach mal alles zusammen gemischt an Wörtern.
Okay, Leute finden es anscheinend übelst geil und die finden es nicht geil.
Watching Videos. Na gut, es ist ja nicht schlimm, wenn es ein Simulator ist mit einer gewissen Tiefe, ist das ja okay.
Das ist irgendwas, das guck ich mir später mal an, das ist jetzt nichts, was ich unmittelbar spielen muss.
Hey Max, findest du Spellforce 3 interessant? Ja, sofern die Bugs mittlerweile behoben sind, dass man das spielen kann.
Argg, nope, nope. Wir sind da eigentlich so die letzten Bewertungen, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Mixed, ja das wundert mich nicht.
Das ist auch so ein Game, Early Access mega erfolgreich gestartet und dann ziemlich abgebaut.
Aber, wollen wir auch sagen, ich habe selten so gehypte Entwickler gesehen wie die von Argg. Und wie gesagt keine Marketing Menschen, sondern wirklich die Entwickler, die an dem Spiel gebastelt haben.
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Das ist irgendwie so ein Physic Game. Ich hoffe nichts in der Qualität eines Goat Simulators.
Physics-Based Puzzle and Exploration Game.
Das Problem, was ich mit solchen Games immer habe ist, die machen mir meistens nach 5 Minuten keinen Bock mehr.
Nee, ich glaube das ist nicht meins.
Streamer Game, ja genau, genau. Sowas in der Richtung hätte ich auch gedacht.
Okay, der Chat sagt das Game ist gut, vielleicht gucke ich mir das irgendwann mal an.
Total War, nope, nicht meine Serie. Nochmal Dark Souls.
Juckt mich aber jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt, großartig. Also habe ich jetzt auch nicht vor.
Skyrim, die 100.000. Auflage. Black Desert Online, das habe ich, halt bloß nicht über Steam.
Bestes MMO zur Zeit, wenn man ein bisschen grinden will und nicht unbedingt auf Dungeon Finder und Raid nach Raid steht.
Fallout 4, nope.
Das ist das Zweite des Reboots, ne? Ich bringe das immer durcheinander in die Tomb Raider Spiele.
Ist das das Zweite? Ich glaube das Rise of the Tomb Raider ist das Zweite. Das Zweite der Neun. Das habe ich noch nicht.
Den ersten Teil habe ich auf der Konsole. Also den ersten Teil ist, es ist mittlerweile so schlimm, ja, wenn du Spiele,
Serien mit erster und zweiter Teil und sowas, das ergibt dann oftmals überhaupt keinen Sinn. Guckt euch jetzt nochmal Battlefront an.
Das gibt es jetzt einfach, gibt es in Battlefront 2, gibt es jetzt zweimal. Und ich bin mal, ich bin echt mal gespannt,
wenn das nächste Battlefield was rauskommt, im Zweiten Weltkrieg spielt, ich hoffe sie sind nicht versucht,
es Battlefield 2 zu nennen. Weil dann wäre echt die Kacke, das wäre einfach mindblown, wisst ihr?
Wenn das Battlefield im Jahr 2018 Battlefield 2 heißen würde. Und irgendwie wäre es auch ziemlich dumm,
wenn es, wenn sie es so wie Call of Duty machen, dass es Battlefield World War 2 heißt. Wäre auch doof.
Sie könnten es mal ganz anders nennen. Oder sie könnten es auch alternativ einfach Battlefield 5 nennen.
Oder, oder wie der Schnetzerorts im Chat schreibt, Battlefield 2.1.
Battlefield 2. Milchmann, du sagst was. Das ist EA Logik. Wahrscheinlich heißt das allen Ernstes Battlefield 2.
Weil sie waren ja auch bei Battlefield 1 immer ganz wild drauf, dass man es halt immer, dass man das so,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das jetzt mit Zahlen schreiben sollte oder mit 1.
Es gab, es gab eine von EA bevorzugte Schreibweise, die sie einem immer nahelegen wollten, so nach dem Motto
Battlefield 1. Wahrscheinlich nennen sie das dann nicht Battlefield 2 als Zahl, sondern Battlefield 2 ausgeschrieben.
Das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen. Das wäre so typisch EA-Taktik.
Was geht ab, Gamers? No Second Plan ist auch da.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken, das neue Civilization. Weiß nicht, ob das was taugt, der Teil.
Und das ist wieder was, wo du 30.000 DLCs brauchst, das du spielen darfst.
Reasonry is mixed. But why? Warum?
Die Leute finden es kacke. Don't buy this. Do not play this. Okay. Okay.
Das neue Civilization bietet weit weniger als das alte mit ganzen DLCs. Ach so.
Das wird natürlich auch die negativen Bewertungen erklären.
Das verstehe ich eh nicht so genau. Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Sims.
Sims hast du einen Teil, da gibt es dann gefühlt 150 DLCs von Haustieren bis Teppichfarben.
In den Tierarzt-DLC oder sonstige Dinge.
Da gibt es dann alles gefühlt und da kommt der neue Sims-Teil raus und da fehlt dann halt alles, was früher als Thanos dazu gekommen ist.
Eigentlich wäre Sims so ein typisches Game, was du so um so ein Buzzword mäßig zu sagen so Game as a Service anbieten kannst.
Hey Max, feierst du heute mit deiner Familie? Mit meiner Mutter. Ja.
Haustier-DLC, beste DLC. Da haben sie... Was war? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir da live vor Ort waren.
Es könnte sein. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir...
Doch, ich glaube, da haben wir vor Ort dagehockt, wo sie für Sims den Haustier, den Haustier-DLC vorgestellt haben.
Und halt so super amazed und toll waren und dann hatten sie noch einen...
Dann hatten sie noch irgendeinen Typ, der hat Tricks mit einem...
Ich weiß nicht, was es für eine Hundetrasse war.
Irgendwelche Hundetricks oder so vorgeführt und hat dann halt versucht, das Publikum für sich zu gewinnen.
Und alle Leute haben nur da gesessen und haben sich gedacht, so ey, das ist Sims, das ist ein Haustier-DLC, so who cares?
Außer halt die üblichen Klatscher, die halt bezahlt werden zum Klatschen, die waren natürlich auch mit am Start.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch am Start? Vor Ort 4-DLC? Nope.
Rust? Nein.
Ohne eine Aussage über das Game treffen zu wollen, da steige ich bestimmt nicht mit ein.
Das haben wir uns gerade schon angeguckt, das Stick-Fighting-Game.
Vor Ort 4, nope, auch keinen Bock drauf.
The Long Dark, das sagt mir was.
Das sagt mir irgendwas, das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Was war denn das nochmal? Ist es das in diesem Naturschutz...
Nee, das war Firewatch oder wie das hieß, in diesem Park.
The Long Dark.
Och nee.
Open World Survival, immer Open World Survival, wo du hinguckst, Open World Survival, fällt denen allen nichts mehr besseres ein.
Das kann nicht auf das Spiel bezogen, das mag ja gut sein, vor allem wenn man sich die Bewertung und so anguckt.
Aber muss es denn immer nur noch Open World Survival sein?
Sieht echt hübsch aus, muss ich sagen.
Gut, die Bäume sehen hässlich aus, ja, aber das von der Belichtung her und so und die Szene an sich sieht echt gut aus.
Das Game ist echt nicht schlecht, okay.
Du, du, du, du, du, du.
Wir machen gleich mal ein bisschen fetzigere Weihnachtsmusik an.
Jetzt habe ich gerade fetzig gesagt, es erinnert mich an den Fanatec Headshot Pro Controller oder wie dieses Ding hieß.
Kennt ihr das noch?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wartet mal Leute, ich muss mal den Browser aufmachen.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt zusammen angucken, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich würde mal kurz die Musik einblenden, Display Capture.
Fassen wir auf, beste.
Beste hier, der Fanatec Headshot Controller, beste.
Wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will, braucht eine Top-Ausstattung.
Und da ist der Fanatec Headshot Controller genau das Richtige.
Das Set besteht aus einem sehr präzisen Gamer-Maus und einem High-Speed-Pad. Zusammen ein unschlagbares Team.
Die Maus ist super ergonomisch und lässt sich an jede Handform anpassen.
Das sorgt auch in langen Gamer-Sessions für ermüdungsfreies Spielen.
Sechs Maus-Buttons und ein 5-Wege Steuerrad sorgen dafür, dass sie ihre Spielfigur auch in heißen Gefechten im Griff haben.
Die Plasmaglide-Mausfüße sorgen zusammen mit dem High-Speed-Pad für minimale Haft- und Gleitreibung für schnelles, präzises Zielen im Spiel.
Wie das aussieht ist nicht...
Das kleine Kabel kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert nicht in die Quere. Dafür sorgt die clevere Kabelführung.
Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben, Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz machen das Spiel noch rasanter.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Das hier, das ist das beschissenste Mauspungi, was ich jemals gesehen habe.
Das sieht aus wie eine Sicherungskette für Einkaufswagen, ey.
Die fetzigen, pass auf jetzt, die fetzigen Leuchteffekte, die müssen wir uns noch mal angucken.
Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz machen das Spiel noch rasanter. Profi-Gamer sind begeistert von den Programmiermöglichkeiten für Maus und Tastatur, selbst während des Spiels. Auch Makros lassen sich problemlos einsetzen.
Damit sind sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen und anderen Games der King.
Der King!
Der Fnatic Headshot Controller ist das ultimative Set für Gamer und wetten, dass er auch als Geschenk gut ankommt. Probieren Sie es aus.
Das ist so schlecht.
Oh Mann.
Das ist, wisst ihr, das sind Sendungen, die richten sich an irgendwelche Omas oder so, die ihren Enkeln was zu Weihnachten schenken sollen und nicht wissen was.
Und was weiß ich, der Enkel hat sich irgendwie eine neue, neue Gaming-Maus, neue Tastatur, was auch immer gewünscht. Er kriegt jetzt den Fnatic Headshot Controller.
Hey, da haben wir das Neue ins Auspark doch, wo wir gerade dabei waren.
Ja, ich bin geboren da, da bin ich geboren.
1929, easy.
Schmerzt schon, wenn ich's seh.
Warum ist das mixed? Soll doch eigentlich ganz gut sein.
Incredible disappointing.
Ah, okay, es gibt Uplay-Probleme.
Ja gut, Uplay ist ja auch der sinnlosste Scheiß, der jemals erfunden wurde.
Ja, da warte ich erst noch mal mit kaufen.
Quantum Break, ja, das will ich, das wollte ich schon immer mal spielen.
Oh Mann, haben wir ebenfalls übersprungen? Nee. Quantum Break, easy.
Äh.
Ach so, ja, ja, blab.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal spielen.
Ich dachte mir, ich hol's mir für die Xbox, dass ich wenigstens mal ein gescheites Game für die Xbox hab.
Aber ich hab's wieder nie für die Xbox geholt.
Aber ich bin ja ein großer Fan der Remedy Games.
Gab ja nicht so wirklich viele.
Aber sowohl Max Payne 1-2 und Alan Wake sind beides richtig geile Games.
Und Sam Lake kann einfach Storys schreiben.
Add.
Ja komm, aber du, es geht doch, guck mal, da hätten wir jetzt hier schon mal vier nice Games.
Und erster 43, oh, da geht noch was.
Ease YouTube Money, Ease Life.
Aber ansonsten noch.
Der Double Space Programm ist nicht meins. Ist aber ein geiles Game, der halt tüfteln will.
Nope.
Gibt's jetzt auch für die Switch?
Moment, was?
Was soll das für ein Game sein? Das ist doch ein Hardware-Teil.
Damit kann ich dann jetzt meinen Steam auf dem Fernseher oder so streamen.
Aber kann ich auch so, weil ich hab' Nvidia Shield TV.
Und damit kann ich auch streamen. Und das funktioniert wahrscheinlich besser.
The Forest.
Nope.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, warum so viel Open World Survival.
Ob ich irgendwas im Chat übersehe?
Wenn du es im Winner Store kaufst, bekommst du es gerade für die Xbox One, ass mir wurscht.
Ich werde es eh nie auf der Xbox One spielen.
Oh, das war nice. Das war auch nice.
Also wenn irgendjemand auch noch ein bisschen düsteres Game sucht, hier, sehr nice.
Vor allem in Anbetracht des Budgets, was sie da gesichtsanimationstechnisch gemacht haben.
Echt nice.
Gameplay-technisch war ein bisschen doof.
Aber es war von Anfang bis Ende spannend.
Super als Voice-Over, schön Sprachausgabe und super Animation. War echt cool.
Hallo? Steam?
Äh, Steam?
Äh, nope. Aber hab' ich es eh schon.
Haben wir uns schon angeschaut? Nächstes... Moment, Moment. Sehe ich das richtig?
Sekunde. 995?
Das werde ich mir nicht alles angucken können.
995? Vielleicht sollte ich das mal filtern nach Sachen, die mich interessieren.
Relevanz. Es ist ja schon nach Relevanz sortiert, was auch immer Relevanz ist.
Was ist das? Sieht nach Echtzeitstrategie so ein bisschen aus.
Mit Figuren, die aussehen wie Mies.
Ach, Early Access, okay. Und Tschüss.
Kann man Early Access rausfiltern? Ich will Early Access filtern.
So was, not Early Access. Geht das auf... Weiß jemand, ob das auf Steam geht?
Dass ich sagen kann, ich will kein Early Access oder so, not Early...
Ich will Early Access rausfiltern, geht das irgendwie?
Nee, natürlich nicht. Kein Wunder, dass man das nicht mehr durchblickt.
So, jetzt machen wir mal ein bisschen was Zackiges an.
Hier haben wir mal Irish Christmas Music.
Vielleicht sollten wir doch hier nach den Empfehlungen gehen.
Weil 995 Seiten kann ich mir nicht angucken, das ist ein bisschen viel.
Harry's Mortimer schon, Terraria ist alt. Alex! Weiß ich nicht.
Kann man mein Profil einstellen, okay?
Wenn ich irgendwann mal spiele, aber nicht in nächster Zeit.
Survival? Das sieht schon irgendwie anhand der Bilder.
Survival? Nice, sehr nice gewesen.
Habe ich schon durchgespielt? Sogar Let's Plays auf YouTube?
Tekken Sie? Nope. Shadow of Lootbox? Nope.
Survival? Nope. Nope. Nope. Gibt es irgendwas, was mich interessiert?
Nein, Survival. Es ist krass zu sehen, wie viel Survival am Start ist, oder?
Filter by Selected Types nur nach Games und Bundles, das ist eine gute Idee.
Es sind ja nur noch 551 Seiten. Hast du das neue Wolfenstein gespielt?
Nein, habe ich nicht, weil...
Weil, ich zeige es euch gleich, falls es überhaupt dabei steht.
Das da! Deswegen!
Mir ist es scheiß egal, ob die Hakenkreuze oder sonstige Symbole aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
oder Zeitraum herum rausgeschippen haben. Das ist mir egal.
Das verstehe ich ja. Hey, das verstößt tatsächlich gegen Deutsch.
Ist okay. Aber keine englische Sprachausgabe. Was soll denn der Scheiß?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mich nicht gekauft.
Gibt es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, weiß das jemand, dass Wolfenstein 2 in Deutschland zu bekommen
halt mit englischer Sprache?
Bei irgendeinem anderen Shop oder so?
Oder ist einfach schlicht und ergreifend die Version halt ohne Englisch?
Ich meine, ansonsten ist es mal wieder so ein typischer Fall von
Gehst du dir das illegal runter, kriegst du das bessere Spiel.
Was wir ja hier kein anstiften wollen.
Das ist einfach so der Fail, was früher auch die Musikindustrie und sowas gemacht hat.
Man hat den Leuten permanent ein schlechtes Gewissen eingeredet.
Kennt ihr noch von Filmen früher, und ich weiß nicht, ob es das immer noch gibt,
vor den Filmen so dieses, Mama, wo ist Papa? Im Knast, weil er Raub kopiert hat.
Da war ein Werbespot da, wo ich mir auch immer gedacht habe,
ich würde viele Sachen gerne im Original kaufen, wenn es sie denn gäbe in Deutschland.
Und nicht irgendwie erst ein Jahr später mit kack Tonspur, eventuell gar nicht,
eventuell mega teuer.
Die Leute sind ja prinzipiell bereit, sich das alles original zu kaufen,
wenn es da was ordentliches gibt.
So.
So viel Joy.
Moment.
Ah, ich bin falsch.
Specials.
Games.
Jetzt gefiltert, Games Bundles.
Okay.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Was haben wir uns schon alles angeguckt?
Wir gucken jetzt noch ein bisschen durch, selbst 551 Seiten kriegen wir nicht hin,
das ist ja schon nach Relevance sortiert.
Übrigens danke für die Follows, ich muss mal reingucken.
Hab ich es denn hier?
So.
Genau, genau Bestie, das meine ich.
Raubkopieren mit bis zu sieben Jahren.
Dass man das vor allem sich, das Beste ist ja, dass dieser komische Werbespot immer vor Filmen lief,
wenn man die sich gekauft hat.
Also sprich, du hast dir den Film ehrlich gekauft oder was auch immer oder warst im Kino und sonst was,
sprich, du gibst Geld dafür aus und dann musst du dir erstmal anhören,
wie schlimm es ist, Raub zu kopieren.
Sam Fischer, ich hab gerade das Fenster refreshed, ich hab nicht gesehen, was du geschrieben hast.
Das haben wir sonst noch hier schon, das haben wir uns noch schon alles angeguckt.
Das sieht auf den ersten Blick schon mal nach dem coolen Grafikstil aus.
Also der Grafikstil gefällt mir.
Weihnachtlicher wird es ja nicht mehr jetzt ey, jetzt wird es nicht mehr Weihnachtlicher.
Warum muss Maria eigentlich unbedingt Virgin sein, das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden.
Vor allem der arme Josef ey, was hat er denn die ganze Zeit denkt.
Egal, wir wollen uns jetzt nicht so im Detail mit beschäftigen.
Wir sind hier ein christlicher Stream.
Kann man sowas ja nicht erzählen.
Das sieht nice aus, ich hab keine Ahnung um was es geht.
Rook Lite Metro Metroidvania Action Platformer.
Boah krass, da haben sie ja wieder.
Man ist heute nicht mehr nur eine Sache bei einem Game, man ist nicht mehr ein Genre,
man ist heute Rook Lite Metroidvania Action Platformer.
Es sieht aber cool aus, Early Access nein.
Ich hab mir vorgenommen Leute, egal was es ist, wenn ich nicht schon mal ein Spiel,
wenn die nicht schon mal irgendein Early Access Spiel gemacht haben, was erschienen ist
und dann auch halbwegs was getaugt hat, ich kauf mir keinen Early Access mehr.
Ich seh es mittlerweile echt nicht mehr ein.
So viel Shit, der bei Early Access drin ist und nie fertig wird.
Guckt euch mal Dates an.
Dates kommt jetzt demnächst raus, keine Stauwilds mehr haben.
Hat irgendwie vier Jahre in Early Access geschimmelt und das war's.
Oh, das ist für die ganzen Anime Fans hier.
Bei The Tales of Raya hab ich komplett den Überblick verloren, was da jetzt wie aktuell ist.
Früher ging das ja noch irgendwie, da kam so alle zwei Jahre mal ein Teil raus,
heute kommt gefühlt auf jeder Plattform jeden Jahr ein Teil raus, da blickst du immer durch.
Außerdem wird das immer abgedreht, ey ich mein hallo.
Kann ich nicht einfach eine Rüstung anziehen?
Der Typ hier, übelste Schulter, Panzerung und alles und die so nein, hier bauchfrei, easy.
Bestgeschützte Parts hier am ganzen Körper hier, von oben bis da.
Tales of Symphonia auf dem Gamecube war noch cool.
Und auch das für die 360, was es gab.
Mittlerweile hab ich da voll den Überblick verloren bei der Reihe.
Seven Days to the, also das ist ja auch, Moment.
Das hab ich jetzt verwechselt.
Das ist, das sieht ja, nein, nein.
Das wollt ich spielen.
Das wollt ich spielen, das neue Resident Evil.
Beziehungsweise Biohazard, also je nachdem in welchem Land man das kauft.
Das ist ja auch witzig irgendwie, das ist.
Das heißt ja irgendwie in Japan heißt der Biohazard, bei uns heißt es Resident Evil
und bei uns heißt dieser Teil Resident Evil Biohazard und Japan als Resident Evil.
Mind blown.
Echt, wenn man sich da zu lange Gedanken drüber macht, dann platzt der Kopf.
Okay, das ist ja wieder so der typische Fall von, es gibt nicht einfach nur das Game.
Es gibt wieder, okay, vergesst was ich sagen wollte, es geht ja noch.
Es gibt wieder 20 verschiedene Editions, wo man nicht weiß, was man sich kaufen soll.
Das werd ich mir aber auf jeden Fall noch holen.
Nicht jetzt.
Er hat, er hat aber echt alles.
Er hat einfach alles.
Auf jedem Game, wo wir gucken, ist er am Start.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Sniper Elite 4, das haben wir schon.
Nein, das ist nicht meins.
Also Naruto ist doch mittlerweile eh out, oder?
Ist das nicht sogar fertig?
Ist Naruto nicht fertig mittlerweile?
Ich hab irgendwo mal gelesen.
Und es gibt jetzt ja wohl irgendwie ein Sequel, so rum, irgendwie mit dem Sohn von Naruto dann und sowas.
Äh, nein.
What the fuck ist das?
Okay, das sind die, die, äh, Metal-Dings.
Wie heißt's?
Ey, ich hab übelst Probleme in letzter Zeit mir Sachen zu merken, wie was heißt.
Brutal Legends mein ich, genau.
What the fuck?
Was soll das sein?
Multiplayer Party Game, nein, das brauchen wir nicht.
Hab ich irgendwas überlesen im Chat?
Was wird's denn real, ja.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Time, das will ich haben.
Das will ich haben.
Was ich auch ganz witzig finde, dass Hüte dieses Jahr bei Plattformern ganz voll im Trend sind.
Also es gab zwei richtig gute Plattformer mit Hüten.
Einmal Head & Time und halt, dann das andere wär ich ja kaum erzählen müssen, das wisst ihr eh.
Video, Deluxe Edition.
Das wollte ich aber schon die ganze Zeit mal spielen.
Hopp.
Was ist Hopp?
Bestimmt ein Unity-Game.
Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht.
Es schreit irgendwie so ein bisschen danach.
Auch wenn man das nicht wirklich erkennen kann.
Zumindest ich kann das eigentlich erkennen, weil ich niemals damit gemacht hab, großartig.
Was soll das sein?
Transform the World of Hopp.
A New Action Adventure from Runic Games.
Runic Games?
Moment, was war das?
Haben die nicht auf der Switch letztens irgendwas released?
Muss ich mal gucken, der Name sagt mir irgendwas noch.
Was hat Runic Games gemacht?
Ach nein, Torchlight.
Ah, die sind das.
Hätte ich gar nicht googlen müssen, steht ja sogar drunter.
Torchlight?
Okay, das hat mit Torchlight aber relativ wenig zu tun.
Dann haben sie zumindest eine, wenn man gescheite Games macht.
Aber es sieht nicht so aus, als wäre es jetzt was, was ich unmittelbar spielen müsste.
Lies doch einen Satz weiter, jetzt weißt du, wie das mit Handbüchern lesen ist.
Nemo Chains.
Ich google das lieber, bevor ich das lese.
Borderlands 2 hab ich gespielt.
Noch auf der...
Mist, das Ziel 360.
Mit dem Friseur zusammen.
Ein Ge...
Okay.
What the fuck?
Ich kann nicht mehr Prügelspiel.
Me Weep, Me Spam, Mothbucker, Ifban.
Nein.
Steam.
H1Z1.
Warum hab ich mir dieses Game überhaupt gekauft?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Warum hab ich mir das gekauft?
Ich hab mir das schon vor 2 Jahren oder so gekauft.
Warum?
A Visual Novel ist es, okay.
Hype Train, ja wahrscheinlich wegen dem Hype Train hab ich mir das gekauft.
Warum hab ich mir das gekauft?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Bringt mir nichts, weil ich kein VR hab.
Kann ich es nicht ausschließen?
Kein VR?
Das müssten die bei Steam echt machen.
Das ist negative Text.
Also du könntest sagen, ich will alles außer VR und sowas.
Dann hätten wir auch keine 500 noch was sein.
Ich hab überhaupt kein VR.
Age of Empires 3 Complete Edition.
Haben wir schon.
Geiles Game.
Zwar alt, aber geiles Game.
Das kam doch nicht erst 2012 raus.
Das ist doch viel älter, Age of Empires 3.
Das kam doch 2007 oder so.
Das ist doch alt.
Ja 2005 kam das raus.
Weiß auch nicht, was das Steam anzeigt.
Wahrscheinlich die Complete Edition kam 2012 raus.
Kingdom and Castles.
Das ist auch neu und hat ein bisschen Hype.
Kann das sein?
Da schwingt irgendwas im Kopf bei mir, wenn ich diesen Namen lese.
Kingdoms and Castles.
Das hab ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Mittelalterlicher Städte-Bausimulator.
Von Fick.
Manche Sachen sind echt unglücklich in anderen Sprachen, oder?
Das ist Early Access.
Das ist nicht Early Access.
Das ist ein Pluspunkt.
Okay.
Nee, das guck ich mir vielleicht irgendwann an.
Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Was hatten wir schon auf Lootbox?
Da waren wir doch schon.
Ich bin auf der Seite.
Hier zurück.
Nein.
Das ist doch noch ein 360-Game oder so.
Never ist das von 2016.
Das ist ein Xbox 360-Game, wenn ich jetzt nicht total falsch liege.
Life is Strange Before the Storm.
Nein.
Irgendwann war aber nicht in nächster Zeit.
Wollte ich mir schon die ganze Zeit mal angucken.
Aber es ist bestimmt ein Game, womit man sich beschäftigen muss.
Was war denn das nochmal?
War das dieses Ninja-Taktik-Stealth-Game?
Hardcore Tactical Stealth-Game Set in Japan.
Ja, genau das.
Das waren so quasi Kommandos in Japan.
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Das sah ganz cool aus.
Das habe ich auch gewischt irgendwann.
Also ich benutze diese Wischt-Licht ja nicht, weil ich will, dass mir das jemand kauft oder so.
So einfach, dass ich mir das merken kann.
Zurück.
Steam.
Steam checkt das nicht so ganz, glaube ich.
Evil Within?
Nope.
Kein Bock drauf.
Echt keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist so ein Game, was...
Es muss ja...
So von dem, was ich gelesen habe, ist ja sowohl der erste, noch der zweite Teil gar nicht wirklich schlecht.
Aber...
Schock gestattet.
Er hat echt alles.
Schon wieder.
Ey.
Äh.
Wer auf viel Text steht, mit guter Story, kann sich das hier kaufen.
Zumal die Enhanced Edition wirklich viel besser aussieht als das Original.
Viel, viel besser.
Als das Original.
Im Original war die Auflösung ungefähr so hier, wie diese eine Ecke.
Aber Landscape, das war schon ein geiles Game.
Nope, nope.
Farming Simulator?
Nein.
Zu Zeiten, als es noch Hack'n'Slay war, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Farming Simulator, 2017.
Farming in 2K17, lull.
Das nächste.
Call of the Wild.
Ein Jagdspiel.
Jawoll.
Nein.
Age of Mythology.
Extended.
Das ist doch auch schon uralt.
Warum hat das alles Release Date 2014?
Das ist auch so von 2000.
Was weiß ich?
2004 oder so?
Das ist uralt.
Golfit.
Mini Golf oder sowas.
Nein, das...
Hoffentlich.
Metal Gear Solid.
Nein, auch kein Bock drauf.
Das zeigt schon gar keine Vorschaubilder mal an.
Hat keinen Bock mehr.
Nein.
Tabletop Simulator.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, ist das im Endeffekt, um Games in einem Game zu
spielen, oder?
Oh, jetzt wird es aber echt Inception-mäßig.
Wenn es in einem Spiel ein Tablet gibt mit Android drauf, wo man wieder ein weiteres Spiel
und vielleicht das gleiche Spiel spielen kann, indem man wieder ein Tablet hat mit Android
drauf, wo man das Spiel...
Nein.
Das schafft mein Gehirn gerade nicht.
Es ist aber ein Spiel, um Spiele zu spielen.
Es gibt schon mal die passenden Würfel, um Dungeons und Dragons spielen zu können.
Mit VR wäre das natürlich übelst geil.
Das ist dann wirklich schon Next-Gen.
Also sprich, anstatt dass man sich mit seinen Kumpels...
Ich meine, das ist jetzt wirklich nicht negativ.
Anstatt dass man sich mit seinen Kumpels an Tisch setzt in echt und das spielt, kann
man sich dann quasi virtuell an Tisch setzen und spielen, was natürlich in der heutigen
Zeit unglaubliche Vorteile hat, weil man nicht zusammen in dem gleichen Raum sein muss.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Da könnten wir eigentlich unser D&D-Zeug drin spielen.
Was ist mein Name?
Das wird mich nicht wundern.
Okay.
Vom Namen her ist es ein Kunstgame.
Oder auch nicht.
Lifter, der Treppenlift.
Interessiert mich nicht.
Ich bin gerade dazu gekommen.
Was ist denn schon im Einkaufskorb?
Zeige ich dir.
Wenn ich wüsste, wie man auf den Einkaufskorb kommt.
Wie kommen wir auf den Einkaufskorb?
Hier, Karte.
Das haben wir zurzeit im Kart drin.
Er hat in Time, Quantum Break, Cuphead, Hollow Knight und das erste South Park-Spiel.
Also aus South Park RPG-Spiel.
Slime Ranger.
Also wenn ein Spiel einen richtig dummen Namen hat, dann ist es ja mal Slime Ranger.
Was ist das?
What the fuck?
Was sehe ich da?
Also ich habe jetzt das Video gesehen und ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da gesehen habe, ehrlich gesagt.
Ihr könnt jetzt ja meinen Gesichtsausdruck gerade nicht sehen, aber es ist so...
Oh, was geht?
Machst du Sauchschleim ein und züchtest den dann?
Braucht man da zu einem Game?
Elite Dangerous.
Warum hat er so schlechte Bewertung?
Das hat doch ganz gut gestartet.
Wie gewinnt man da?
Was weiß ich?
Ich habe es nicht gespielt.
Zumindest Slime einzaugen kann man, wenn man da drauf steht, auch ohne ein Spiel.
Wenn es einem gefällt.
Und es gibt ja, egal, man kann davon ausgehen, egal was für kranke Sachen man sich ausdenken kann.
Du wirst auf der Welt mindestens einen finden, der es geil findet.
Deswegen gibt es bestimmt auch Leute, die gerne Slime einzaugen.
Das ist doch übelst gut gestartet.
Warum hat es jetzt so schlechte Bewertung?
Was ist da los?
Okay, anscheinend hat es, wenn man das eine Weile spielt, ist es nicht so geil.
Okay, der Cryin' ist real.
Das war nice.
Das würde ich gerne mal spielen.
Ich meine, ich kenne zwar fast das ganze Game, weil ich da schon so viele Streams und Speedruns und Videos und so.
Aber das Game ist echt nice.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es noch selbst spielen soll, weil ich kenne es halt schon.
Starborn, nope.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Dishonored, haben wir schon.
Nochmal Dark Souls.
Dark Souls wollen sonst aber von vorne bis hinten, an jeder Ecke kriegst du Dark Souls empfohlen.
Empire S2, Injustine 9, Future Infinite habe ich gespielt auf der 360 glaube ich noch.
Oder PS4? 360, PS4?
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Es sah ganz gut aus.
Also wahrscheinlich PS4.
Ich weiß nicht.
XCOM 2 irgendwann mal ist definitiv ein gutes Game.
Hearts of Iron, nein.
Das sieht mir nach irgendeinem World Map Strategy Game Truppenraumgeschicke aus.
Das ist nichts für mich.
Stellaris hatte mal in der Zeit ein bisschen Hype, sagt mir irgendwas, hat mich aber auch nicht interessiert.
Oder gab es für die...
Was soll ich jetzt misst erzählen?
War das für die Wii der erste Teil?
Da ging der Friseur damals total drauf ab, auf das erste Bayonetta.
Das hat er bis im höchsten Schwierigkeitskart mit allem durchgespielt, gefühlt drei Monate lang.
Farmers Dynasty, nee.
Killing Floor 1, die kennen wir schon ein bisschen her.
Killing Floor 2 habe ich die Beta gespielt.
War sinnlos im Kreis, Monster gebasher, hat mir nicht gefallen.
Telltale, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Flugsimulator.
Toml1 Simulator, nein.
Watch Dogs 2, nein, nein, nein.
Hitman Absolution, war nice.
Steep, was ist... Ach das ist dieses Snowboard Game.
Das ist auch nicht meins gewesen, Dishonored 2.
Wollte ich irgendwann auch mal spielen, aber erstmal nicht.
Ich hab gehört letztens irgendwo, dass...
Dishonored 2 finanziell nicht so gut gewesen ist.
Würde mich eigentlich wundern.
Nachdem der erste Teil da wirklich...
Ziemlich gut war und ich glaube auch ziemlich erfolgreich.
Project Cars, nein, kein Bock auf Rennspiele.
BeamNG Drive.
Kein Bock auf Rennspiele, Endless Space 2.
Klingt nach Survival.
Ist bestimmt Survival.
Ich wette mit euch Survival.
Strategic Space Opera Featuring.
Just One More Turn Gameplay. Aha.
Ok, es ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Survival im Weltraum.
Das klingt mich ein bisschen an Homeworld, wenn ich das so sehe.
Kennt das noch jemand, Homeworld?
Also das erste.
Was damals grafisch extrem geil war mit den Raumschiffen.
Da muss man zu viel denken, das krieg ich heute nicht hin.
Battlestar Galactica Deadline.
Das klingt schon...
Das zählt nicht unter Titel.
Ich habe keinen Bock drauf.
Nicht Skyrim, diesmal ist es Oblivion.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Manche Sachen sehen schon irgendwie so aus, als ist es nichts für mich.
Das wollte ich mal spielen.
Das ist von Obsidian, glaube ich.
Ja.
Das wollte ich spielen.
So release schon.
Bin ich aber irgendwie nicht zugekommen.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es auch ein Game, was eine Weile dauert.
Und wenn ich da an Pillars of Eternity denke,
das konnte man ja auch gut und gerne mal 80 Stunden spielen.
Das ist von den gleichen Typen.
Also Obsidian Entertainment hat schon vieles in dieser Richtung gemacht.
Oh, es gibt eine Pillars of Eternity 2.
Gibt es dann einen Early Access oder Crowd Founding oder was ist das?
Da freue ich mich drauf.
Wusste noch gar nicht, dass es in der Entwicklung ist.
Hast du schon mal Spellforce 3 ausprobiert?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe bloß gelesen, dass es verbackt sein soll wie Sau.
Dementsprechend dachte ich mir, ich warte einfach noch mal.
Also ich glaube, so die Top Games haben wir jetzt durch,
wenn ich hier angucke, was jetzt hier noch kommt.
Moment, ich bin falsch.
Just Cross 3, nein.
Atmosphäre wirklich super.
Oh, wenn wir da beim Thema sind, er hat alles.
Angeblich das bessere SimCity von allem, was ich gelesen habe, nie ausprobiert.
Habe ich beim Lost im Stream mal gesehen, sah ganz spaßig aus.
Aber es schockt mich alles nicht so.
Übelsgeiles Game hier, hallo.
Übelsgeiles Game, Darkest Dungeon.
Gab es jetzt auch letztens in Add-on zu?
Dungeon Crimes, so 2,5D, wenn man die Mini Übersichtskarte mit einbrechnet,
da eigentlich eher 2D.
Irgendwie spricht mich da gerade nicht so wirklich was an.
Das habe ich mir auch mal irgendwann gekauft, habe ich, habe ich nicht.
Wollte ich glaube ich mal, als es neu war.
Irgendwie spricht mich gerade nicht mehr so viel an.
Was ist das?
WTF?
Was zum, das ist so ein typisches japanisches Game, oder?
Das muss ein japanisches Game sein.
Das können nur japanische Games sein.
Riesenameisen überfallen irgendeine Stadt und du musst sie bashen.
Das kann nur ein japanisches Game sein.
Und hast eine MG, die aussieht wie eine Armbrust, wo man nicht weiß,
warum die so aussieht wie eine Armbrust, weil es eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn hat,
dass sie aussieht wie eine Armbrust.
Das muss, das muss ein japanisches Game sein, das geht gar nicht anders.
Ach du Scheiße, es ist, japanischer geht es ja gar nicht mehr.
Ist das Multiplayer?
Player's Forte für Coop.
Coop ist jedes Game spaßig.
Das wollen wir im Stream sehen, so so.
Das ist doch das Lieblingsgame von all der vier Games, ist es das?
Im japanisch kann es nicht sein, Game, glaube ich.
Ich weiß, das sieht sogar ganz spaßig aus, irgendwie.
Das ist halt im Prinzip wahrscheinlich sowas wie sinnlose Endlos-Horde-Modus im Coop,
einfach Monster bashen.
Tausend Spielstunden hast du da drin.
Das kann man sich mal auf jeden Fall merken.
Nein, wenn ich so einen Titel schon, das liest sich nach Survival.
Sieht aber nicht so aus wie Survival.
Aber Grafikstil hat mir jetzt nicht so gefallen.
Autorennspiele, nein, Far Cry 4 haben wir schon.
Castle Crusher ist auch nice, aber schon uralt.
Halo Wars, nein.
This War of Mania, wenn ich deprimiert sein will zu Weihnachten, dann spiele ich das.
Also wenn einer zu gut drauf ist, zu dieser Jahreszeit und sich ein bisschen mal
ein bisschen deprimiert sein will, dann kann er This War of Mine spielen.
Oder er spielt To The Moon.
Da kann er eine Runde heulen.
E-Sport, null.
Kartenzeug.
Ich bin der ersten Teil, als ich mich mal angeschaut habe.
Irgendwie springt mir gerade nicht Superhot, VR jetzt sogar.
Ich konnte ehrlich gesagt die Begeisterung Superhot nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Sword and Sanctuary ist das, wenn man zu viel Overwatch ranked gespielt hat.
Das ist quasi Overwatch ranked als eigenes Game.
Sword and Sanctuary.
So, was ist?
Hallo?
Ich hab draufgeklickt, Steam.
Steam, ich hab draufgeklickt.
Siehstealer finde ich ganz nice.
Ach nee, das ist wieder irgend so ein Open-World-Random-Generated-Sonst-Was-Survival-Zeugs, oder?
Na, ist nett.
Wo haben wir denn hier aufgehört?
Heute kein Overwatch, nee.
Leute, ich kann's aber sagen, wirklich super Game.
Wenn ihr ein Spiel sucht mit sehr viel Herz, dann holt euch Finding Paradise.
Ein Game, was ich prinzipiell auch gern noch mal im Stream durchspielen würde, was ganz gut ist, weil es ist komplett auf Englisch.
Das heißt, ich muss das irgendwie so sinngemäß übersetzen, während ich da spiele.
Und manche Dialoge haben Wörter drin, wo ich selbst erst mal nachgucken musste, wo ich gedacht hab, was wollt ihr eigentlich?
Aber nachdem ich quasi so die letzte Stunde von dem Game übelst geheult hab,
ich hab gedacht, ist das vielleicht nicht das beste Onstream?
Oder vielleicht wäre das gerade das beste Onstream?
Keine Ahnung.
Torchline 2, ja, das ist schon abgehalten.
Pro Evolution Soccer, nein.
Fußballspiele, nein.
Nein!
Muss auch nicht sein.
Noch mehr Superhot.
Crimdon.
Diabloschnetz Lore.
Sprich mich aber auch nicht so richtig an.
Fowler, nope.
Heat Signage, äh.
Was ist das?
Äh.
Hä?
Okay, das ist definitiv ein Game, wo ich anhand der Screenshots keine Ahnung hab, um was es geht.
Was passiert da überhaupt?
Äh.
Hä?
Okay, ich versteh nicht, um was es geht.
Irgendein Weltraumstelle, das ist Turtle Sea, sonst war es Game.
Ein Rook-like Raumschiff-Einbrechspiel.
Okay, wenn du das so sagst.
Ton an, da gibt es bestimmt einfach nur epische Musik.
Oh nee, da wird was erklärt, fuck.
Das hätte ich vielleicht doch den Ton anmachen sollen.
So.
Äh, was haben wir denn sonst noch so?
Na.
Das soll ganz nice sein, was ich gelesen hab.
Moment.
Online Morrowind?
What?
Ah, das ist ein Addon für Elder Scrolls Online, was zufälligerweise Morrowind heißt, wo man quasi in dem Gebiet spielt.
Vom damaligen Singleplayer-Spiel.
Fragezeichen, wahrscheinlich.
Maxi wäre es, du lädst dir Unity runter und wir entwickeln zusammen ein Spiel.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von Unity.
Außerdem bräuchte man da erstmal eine gute Idee.
Space Engineers.
Das sieht ein bisschen so was aus wie Kerbal Space Program.
Nein.
Die Lego-Spiele, finde ich, haben auch ganz schön nachgelassen.
Ich fand die ersten paar Lego-Games mega nice.
So Lego-Indiana Jones und was war denn das nächste?
Mir fällt eigentlich bloß an Lego-Indiana Jones ein.
Die ersten Lego-Games fand ich übelst nice.
Danach, finde ich, hat es irgendwie nachgelassen.
Warum ein bisschen immer das Gleiche, ja.
Stalker.
Nice Games.
Er hat echt alle Games.
Soma.
Was ist Soma?
Ah, die Typen sind das, okay.
Science-Fiction-Horror-Games set below the waves of the Atlantic Ocean.
Struggle to survive.
Das klingt aber schon wieder so nach Survival und Open World.
Also warum gibt es so viele Survival-Open-World-Games?
Die müssen ja noch nicht mal schlecht sein, aber ich finde,
das ist mittlerweile so ausgelutscht.
So ausgelutscht wie Zombie-Survival oder Mobars oder so.
Ohne, dass das hier schlecht sein muss.
Weil, wenn man sich die Bewertung anguckt, ist das wahrscheinlich sogar ziemlich gut.
Der Masterflug, das stimmt.
Fürs Spiele programmieren braucht man keine Ahnung.
Einfach Early Access und fertig.
Wenn man sich anguckt, wie viele Scheiß-Spiele mittlerweile im Early Access hier rumschimmeln,
wo sich Leute quasi das SDK runtergeladen haben oder irgendeinen Engine mit ein paar Demos drinne.
Im Demo-Level hinsetzen drei Bäume rein und sagen dann hier
Next-Gen-Ultrakrasser-Sonstwas-Shooter und wollen dann 15 Euro für Early Access.
Und am besten bauen sie noch irgendwas ein, was so richtig schlecht ist,
dass dann Let's-Player kommen können und Funny-Streams drüber machen,
und Funny-Videos drüber machen.
Es gibt so viele Spiele, was es nicht alles gab.
Goat Simulator, Crash Simulator.
Es gibt bestimmt auch Shit Simulator wahrscheinlich mittlerweile.
So Kack-Games eigentlich.
So richtig dummes Zeug, wo es alle mega lustig finden,
dass irgendwelche Physik-Sachen nicht richtig funktionieren.
Irgendwelche Ragdoll-Geschichten nicht richtig funktionieren.
Und alle hoho, ist es lustig, lululul, dass wir alle hier Let's-Play machen.
Wir sind da auch in Teil, also die ganzen YouTube-Let's-Play-Geschichten
und diese Funny-Let's-Play sind auch zum Teil mit dran schuld, dass es so viele Scheiß-Games gibt.
Tree Simulator, was auch immer es da alles gibt.
Der Hand Simulator, sind wir doch gerade dabei.
What the fuck?
Was zum Teufel ist der Hand Simulator?
Warum?
Wer hat diese Models erstellt?
Und warum ist das mostly positive?
Das sieht schon absolut nach unfertigem Kack aus.
Das hat so der Poppe in letzter Zeit gespielt.
Ja, genau nach so einem Game sieht es aus.
Da warst du Patient Simulator.
Sollten sie mal so nennen, das Ding, ja.
Erinnert mich irgendwie an Reaper, wenn er portet.
So, wir brauchen neue Weihnachtsmusik, das ist fertig.
Wir brauchen, okay, ich gehe jetzt zu YouTube.
Best Christmas Songs.
Mal gucken, was es da gibt.
Top Christmas Songs of all time.
Okay, wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt grausam.
Max, schaust du dir eigentlich Game Star an?
Ja, ab und zu.
Oh, nee.
Best Christmas, Moment, das müssen wir...
Ja, das muss sein.
Bisschen leise, oder?
So.
Ist das Falco?
Nee, das sind die Toten Rosen.
Nein, die Roten Rosen, sorry.
So, was haben wir jetzt hier noch?
Cringe.
So, was gibt es denn hier sonst noch schönes Steam?
Golf is your friends, nein.
Vanquish, nein.
Hollow Knight ist im Angebot, dazu kann ich bloß sagen,
Card Hollow Knight, bam.
Du kannst mal nach Rainbow Six Seed schauen, vielleicht ist das im Angebot.
Ja, das ist im Angebot, das habe ich mir aber schon gekauft.
Gestern, vorgestern, vorgestern.
Moin, Notwehr 87.
Und es sind echt viele Leute dafür, dass da ich einfach nur sinnlos in Steam rumklicke.
Vogel.
Nicht Vogel, Vogel.
Moment, das ist Minecraft aus Vogelsicht.
Was zum...
Okay, bei manchen Games frage ich mich jetzt, warum gibt es die?
Thrilling, ja voll, ist das Thrilling.
Krass, das ist ja so nervenaufreimend.
Der folgt der Grafik aus, ja, ist es auch.
Nein, Vogel, braucht nicht, Moment.
Steam hat es mit der Zurücktaste nicht so wirklich besiegt.
Wird das eigentlich jetzt noch weiterentwickelt?
Das kam ja vor einer Weile schon, ist es eigentlich mittlerweile fertig?
Nein, immer noch Early Access seit 2015.
Wird es jemals fertig wird?
Anscheinend sind die wirklich starker gut dabei und basteln rum.
Ja, Update, 15. Dezember, 18. Dezember.
Level Editor, okay, die sind voll wirklich noch dicke dabei.
Hi, Levi.
Lawbreakers, ist auch so ein Failgame.
Hab ich am Anfang mal kurz überlegt, aber das war so ein Game, was quasi schon
tot bei Release gewesen ist.
Ja, genau so sah es für mich auch aus.
Aber es ist so ein guter Spieler, als das Game kostet.
Ich glaube, die guten Games haben wir jetzt durch.
What the fuck?
Das sieht mir nach einem typischen Game aus.
Ich hab mir Unity runtergeladen und einfach mal.
Cringe Song.
Ist doch eine ganz gute Version davon.
Was empfiehlt uns denn hier Steam?
Bei Anime und Battle Zeug, muss nicht sein.
Ich brauch nochmal irgendein gutes Album Weihnachtslieder.
Was gibt's denn da?
Hat jemand gute Vorschläge?
Ich brauch irgendwie Christmas.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Bad Religion Christmas Song.
Die haben Christmas Song.
Auch sehr nice Band.
Fuck, das sind ja echt Christmas Songs.
Bad Religion hab ich früher sehr viel gehört.
Also, ich glaube wir haben jetzt mehr oder weniger interessante Sachen durchgeguckt.
Das haben wir alle schon hier gesehen.
Was cooles gefällt mir.
Hast du schon A Long Dark gesehen?
Ja hab ich schon gesehen.
Aber hab ich erstmal nicht gekauft.
Batman Man.
Oh, da bin ich mal gespannt was das für Bewertungen hat.
Die Bewertungen müssen wir jetzt mal angucken.
Okay, was hat's für Bewertungen?
Weil das soll ein richtig kacke Remaster sein, was ich bisher so gelesen hab.
Ja, Spielkommen.
Genau, das ist auch so ein Problem.
Naja, was empfiehlen denn meine Friends sonst noch so?
Highlights.
More Highlights.
Chain Simulator, warum ist das based on my preferences, der Train Simulator?
Poly Bridge ist gut.
Okay, was ist das?
Wie viele Anime Games es gibt?
Poly Bridge ist Pitch Builder.
Das ist sowas wie Pitch Builder.
Das ist cool.
Kommen 599.
Ja, das ist sowas wie Pitch Builder.
Nein, ich meine der Marke nicht Pitch Builder.
Das ist ein bisschen komplexere Pitch Builder, wie es ausschaut.
Das ist cool.
Ich überleg grad, was ich denn jetzt kaufe.
Bridge Constructor Portal.
Schaut angeschaut, nein.
Bridge Constructor Portal?
Hat das was mit Portal zu tun oder heißt das einfach nur so?
Das ist Early Access.
Okay, komm, das kaufen wir jetzt.
Das sieht wirklich spaßig aus.
Bridge Constructor Portal.
Fuck, es ist echt Portal.
Es ist...
Dass die Portal verwenden dürfen.
Kauft ihr lieber das?
Ja.
Bei der Gelegenheit, wir müssen jetzt einfach mal...
Alles kaufwärts.
Weil wir können.
Every Mistake.
Da ist mal Instant Coup drauf.
Huge singing skills.
We're releasing on time.
We're still alive.
Wann gibt's ein face reveal wie gesagt bei einer million abos das wird also in nächster zeit nicht so weit sein ich habe mir überlegt
Ich habe mir überlegt ich habe nämlich letztens ein foto von mir gefunden
Da war ich so
Weiß nicht
19 oder sowas so voll mit schleim frisur
Also so voll ordentlich so so mit hemd und und und stings hier also es ist kein turnschuhen mit richtigen schuhen hemd und allem an
voll gel und schleime frisur habe ich da in die kamera gegrinst und
Ich habe mir überlegt ob ich das foto nicht mal in einem video zeigen soll weil
Ich sehe eh nicht mehr so aus ich habe gefühlt die hälfte der haare nicht mehr die ich damals auf dem foto hatte
Also ich wiege bestimmt 20 kilo mehr als auf dem foto
und
Hab nur noch die hälfte der haare also insofern ich glaube man erkennt mich dann eh nicht
Na klatschkopf mags noch nicht es ist aber halt es ist an vielen ist es an einigen ständen stellen schon relativ dünn
Sagen wirs mal so klatze ist es nicht
Damals hatte ich auch noch kein bad
Ja
Ja hast du eigentlich noch was mit dem krieger zu tun die ganze zeit nicht ne
Klaz fbs
Mein bad hofen
Also ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt schluss
Ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
Haben wir ein paar sachen gefunden die man sich geben kann spieletechnisch
Und ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt schluss
Haben wir ein paar sachen gefunden die man sich geben kann spieletechnisch und noch mal gucken ob ich noch irgendein
Wir können nicht mehr hosten
Wer tildet sich den overwatch ab?
Wer tildet sich den overwatch ab den man hosten könnte?
Kamis spielt nicht
Gucken wir hosten jetzt boffer aus
Der mesh der mesh spielt battlefield den könnte man hosten
Komm wir hosten mal den mesh
Den wollte ich auch noch was aufnehmen in nächster zeit fällt mir gerade so ein
Mario galaxys soundtrack der ist so geil oder vor allem diese stelle hier sag mal warte mal ich spule mal kurz zurück das finde ich so geil
Das hier wartet ja
Das hier ist doch so nice der soundtrack
Was auch richtig geil ist weil wir gerade dabei sind und weil der breast of the wild soundtrack meiner ansicht nach doof war
Ist das das das death roll theme von skyward sword das ist auch geil
Ja
Said
Übels Saxe
So, ihr könnt jetzt noch 7 Minuten.
Nur mal neben Bayer zu Angemerk.
Also, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen.
Wir machen jetzt.. Moment ist der Mesh jetzt off.
Alles klar Leute, macht es gut.
In 5 Minuten,
wenn ihr den Mesh aufschaut,
dann könnt ihr den Mesh aufschalten.
Und dann könnt ihr den Mesh aufschalten.
Also, ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Also, um 14 Uhr gibt es das Video mit dem Fabian.
War mir auf dem Channel.
Bis dann, macht es gut.
Tschüss.